think about that this is why ancient
civilizations certain ones rejected the
concept of money and this is how our
system works today you have a finite
amount of money and you charge interest
on it so how is it possible if there's a
finite amount for everyone to pay back
all the debt in the world you don't hate
to break it to you but it's not possible
there's no technically there's no way to
pay off all the debt in the world no so
as soon as you take money with interest
your shows but which is why it was
illegal until the Renaissance
well maybe illegal the feudal system
read a lot airsoft guns in the studio my
favorite one is this m9 beretta but the
thing is it's broken this is a this is a
quality airsoft gun this is my favorite
to look at like when we talk about stuff
it's it's like a fidget item you know
have you ever fixing their self-image a
I fix airsoft guns all the time how
about this if I fix this I get one
Stevens buck from you a Stevens buck
yeah only the notice Stevens book is
there's this great place nearby where
Nick and I eat lunch almost every day
each lunch meal is one Stevens buck and
sometimes Nick and I trade Stevens bucks
depending on what day it is and who
forgets whose wallet formal currency
yeah between him and I it's form of
currency it's on the rise I think we
should actually print out some Stevens
books if I can fix this all right if you
can fix this I owe you a Stevens buck
here you go
Steve you remember came in
if you had to put in this handrail yeah
absolutely and we have to get a big ol
flammable liquid storage cabinet for all
like our flammable stuff repaint aerosol
to set that up so we have a delivery
[Music]
this longer burnt down so I've been
doing this for the last three years now
we could store all of our spray paint
explosives fireworks her per the border
of the great city of Los Angeles we am
the good Steve and the great Steve we
are required to put this fire cabinet
into our workshop we think we found a
place for it right here no in here we'll
just put it right here it's gonna be
kind of awkward but like it's the best
spot for it no I mean in general that's
pretty awkward because it cuts off no
one goes over there and there's no room
Oh trust me there's still be room yes
see everything I trust and do I gotta
put up with applesauce well that's your
problem right there boy there's an
airsoft BB in the in the hammer
ready ready I'm about to fix this done
by dolly real fire she'll fire look at
all the safety on is it what but now you
can now you can finish your movie scene
where the person has the gun pointed at
the bad guy at the end
hold on these should be stuck
lately look at those Stevens bucks dude
there's a finite supply damn how the
feudal system just valued land over cash
there was a lot of reasons but one of
the reasons was the kings and queens
didn't want people that controlled the
money to have more power than they did
oh yeah that you're right how do we yeah
how do we control this you know I are
you kidding this is freaking beautiful
just put everything you know what this
morning for super cute what would it
cost weight plus delivery everything all
in 370 book really that's it yeah that's
a $1,250 cabinet what are you doing I am
here to take photographs for the
insurance company the fire insurance
company because they requested when he
inspected wishes that I put a handrail
in even though there's never been a
handrail there in 35 years ever built
one immediately and they want me to they
wanted me to put earthquake strapping on
the water heater which I did immediately
and they also said that people that have
flammable materials have to have a real
approved double metal fire and you guys
got one it's unbelievable I got to take
a photograph of this this is just like
beautiful man man just you know we know
what was weird was that I was showing I
said hey look at this this is really
great these guys these are all props or
you know and they make their own swords
they make their own things they shoot
there are things they construct their
own helmets right yeah they they do all
this neat stuff would they fabricate
their own stuff and we're sitting out in
the back in the garden and he goes how
do they fabricate those neat masks and I
went I don't know foam cord they put it
together paint he goes do you think
those masks are flammable go I don't
know I've never lit one on fire I never
know what
he goes because I'm gonna have to
inspect what materials they make the
masks out of and if they do they're
gonna need an approved fire cabinet and
I went what it's how about this I mean
so first of all is it the company that
pays for the Stephens no no no the
company doesn't have anything to do with
this we're talking to Stevens bucks if
we lose one one of these little Stephens
books we have to buy a whole Stephen
each each Stephen buck is worth 14
American dollars it's true in the money
game information is everything and we
can't let them know for every Stephens
buck that I get from you is an lunch at
Stephens that you have to pay for that
is what a Stephens buck means give a
buck to somebody that already owes you
it's just representative of the debt how
do we in debt everybody when we have all
the Bucks so if I get a Stephens buck
from you that's you paying me a big
lunch for me and I get to use that
Stephens bucket anytime I guess I give
you a Stephens back okay now what
happens when I go Stephens I tell you I
want to spend my Stephens buck which
means you have to pay for my lunch yes
so anytime I need another battery ace to
have a man read so so anytime you need
an IOU for Stephens lunch anytime you
hold a Stephens book to have an IOU
oh god that's gonna get confusing so
fast so currently it's an economy okay
so the currents ain't no comic I Got
News for you the style of the entire
reserve system is a calm alright usually
a Stevens but yes so so so so wait so I
do owe you and when I give it to you yes
okay now now when I go to Stevens I can
say I want to spend my Stevens buck that
Jake gave me
so jake has to pay my lunch no one owes
anyone anything but you want a free
lunch I want a free lunch like somebody
should write your name on the but in the
previous thing with the with the gun
mm-hmm since we bet on that and you lost
you'd give me a buck that I would then
hold and tell my name if it's a true
currency the more bucks you have the
better of a position you're in I still
think you should write names make it
specific cuz it is a specific thing it's
not like that means I could you know
what I think I think the only fair rule
is after so here look give me that book
I write my name down on this IOU
students there you go you can cash it in
whenever and then once I pay for your
Stevens you give it back and I burn it
they're worth nothing until I sign my
name on it and then it's worth
everything and it's worth $14 no we're
dramatic we don't hurt her we don't burn
it though we each have a unique seal or
signature only that person can write it
if your sigil is on a Stevens buck and
someone gives it to you you're like look
you go first I was good so that way you
don't have to be connected necessarily
to the debt that like if you and I made
that debt so and you give it to me now I
could make a dad like Bagwell I have a
Knick buck and I can give it to Carl
what's to say it's not gonna get
recirculated unfairly if you don't get
rid of it or destroy it
because you have a good bank yeah it has
to go back to me and yeah I just want to
confirm that yeah but then you hold it
you mean we could just make money with
our residuals on it printing money print
some money yeah this is actually this is
really interesting conversation because
this is kind of how state currency used
to work which is why we had to get off
that system to do this to each other
yeah they do this to each other and be
like well Virginia's got great money but
New Hampshire I don't know about them
yeah you can design whatever bill you
want it's just known it has to have one
one common mark on it that establishes
that as a Stephens budget we should we
have them all up uniform except for the
faces and this
so we are literally making our own
currency for free lunches or anything we
should make them besides of bills
oh let's make them the size of bills
really and then if they're properly so
that means they have to be six inches by
was it two and a half
[Music]